por aquí tenemos una función llamada hdn
y vamos a decir que de manera explícita
define los términos de una sucesión así
que hagamos una pequeña y rápida tabla
por aquí para ver qué me dice esta
función por aquí voy a tener a n y por
aquí voy a tener a h de n
ahora supongamos que n toma el valor de
1 tiene toma el valor de 1 bueno pues
aquí me quedaría menos 31 menos 7 que
multiplica a 1 - 1
ahora date cuenta que uno menos uno me
va a dar cero y por siete me va a dar
cero así que esta parte de aquí se
cancelaría y me quedaría simple y
sencillamente -31 qué pasa si n vale 2
bueno si n vale 2 me quedaría menos 31
menos 7 que multiplica a 2 menos 10 2 -
1 es muy simple esto es 1 por lo tanto
me quedarían menos 7 por 1 lo cual es
menos 7 y entonces menos 31 habrá que
quitarle menos 7 y eso
al menos 38 y 100 a vale 3 bueno pues me
quedaría menos 31 menos 7 por 3 menos
uno lo cual es 27 por 2 ok ahora date
cuenta que en este caso me voy a tomar a
menos 31 y le voy a quitar dos veces 7
es decir me va a quedar menos 31 menos
14 lo cual es menos 45 muy bien pero
veamos que está pasando aquí empezamos
en menos 31 y después cada paso que
nosotros demos vamos a estar quitando 7
otro paso más y por lo tanto vamos a
quitar 7 si te das cuenta eso es lo que
está pasando en esta sucesión es decir
restar 7 una vez menos que la vez que
nos dice el término por ejemplo aquí en
el tercer el término hemos restado 2
veces 7 aquí en este segundo término
hemos restado sólo una vez 7 y bueno es
justo lo que está pasando así que hasta
aquí todo está padre pero ahora lo que
quiero es que pausa
el vídeo y ver si puedes definir la
misma sucesión es decir hasta aquí
tenemos la sucesión menos 31 después
están menos 38 después está menos 45
después el que sigue sería menos 7 sería
menos 52 y así sigue y sigue sigue con
esta misma sucesión lo que quiero es
ahora que encuentres la función
recursiva de esta sucesión ya tenemos
aquí de una manera explícita la sucesión
pero ahora lo que quiero buscar es la
forma recursiva de expresarla ok
entonces manos a la obra lo primero que
quiero que veas es que a esta función la
voy a llamar gdn gdn va a ser mi función
recursiva y bueno esta función es muy
sencilla en primer lugar podemos decir
lo siguiente si n vale 1 que va a pasar
bueno déjame escribirlo
n es igual a 1 nuestro primer término de
esta sucesión recuerda que es menos 31
así que sienna vale 1 nuestro primer
término de esta asociación es menos 31
ahora qué pasa si n es un número más
grande que 1 y bueno como estamos
definiendo una sucesión también debe de
ser un número natural
número natural es decir un entero
positivo y bueno si en el más grande que
uno hay es un número natural como
obtenemos el que sigue
bueno pues muy fácil agarramos el
término anterior es decir que de n
1 ya esto le quitamos 7 date cuenta que
así llegamos al que sigue nos tomamos el
término anterior y le quitamos 7 así que
si agarramos cualquier término al azar
bueno pues nos fijamos en el anterior ya
éste le restamos 7 y obtenemos el
siguiente término y esta función está
muy fácil y muy sencilla date cuenta es
lo siguiente si tú tienes cualquier
término y no sabes cuál es el anterior
bueno te puede seguir regresando y
regresando y regresando todos los
términos hasta llegar al caso base al
inicio en donde n vale 1 y así esta
función me va a definir esta sucesión
perfecto es hora de hacer otro ejercicio
y para eso voy a bajar mi pantalla pero
ahora va a ser el caso contrario voy a
empezar con una función escrita de
manera recursiva y yo lo que voy a
querer es
función que describa esta sucesión pero
de una manera explícita así que veamos
que nos dice esta función lo que nos
dice es que nos da la siguiente sucesión
en el primer término tenemos un 9.6 si n
vale 1
empezamos con 9.6 es nuestro caso base y
después cada término siguiente es el
anterior menos 0.1 así que el segundo
término va a ser el anterior menos 0.1
me va a quedar 9.6 menos 0.1 lo cual es
9.5 el que sigue va a ser el anterior
este menos 0.1 que va a ser 9.4 y
después va a ser 9.3 y así me voy a
mantener siguiendo y siguiendo y
siguiendo siguiendo esta sucesión ahora
también lo podemos hacer en forma de
tabla si yo me tomo por aquí una tabla
déjenme hacer por acá una pequeña tabla
y por aquí voy a poner la otra parte de
la tabla ok en este lado voy a tener a n
y en este otro a hdn y bueno si él no
vale 1 entonces vamos
es el principio 9.6 justo esto es lo que
me dice la función si n vale 1 entonces
mi valor en esa sucesión es 9.6 ahora
qué pasa si en el vale 2 100 abalde 2
entonces voy a tener hd2 menos 1 es
decir hd 1 ya esto habrá que quitarle
0.1 estás de acuerdo en este caso me va
a quedar bueno tengo que fijarme en el
término anterior que es 9.6 ya esto
quitarle 0.1 por lo que me va a quedar
9.5 y quien es ht3 bueno si n vale 3
entonces hd 3 es lo mismo que hd3 menos
1 es decir hd2 menos 0.1 dicho de otra
manera esto va a ser exactamente igual
que hay que fijarnos en hd 2 pero h 2 lo
tenemos aquí es 9.5 y después quitarle
un décimo por lo que me va a quedar 9.4
y así me puedo seguir y seguir y seguir
ahora la pregunta es y lo que quiero que
piense es cómo podemos escribir esta
misma sucesión o esta misma función pero
de una forma explícita ya lo tenemos
aquí de una forma recursiva ahora lo que
quiero es encontrar la forma explícita
de esta sucesión bueno pues vamos a
hacerlo a esta función vamos a llamarle
efe efe
y en un principio parece sencillo
empezamos en 9.6 9.6 y les vamos a
quitar 0.1 pero cuántas veces le vamos a
quitar 0.1 vamos a quitarle una cierta
cantidad de veces primero empezamos con
9.6 y no le quitamos 0.1 y en el segundo
término date cuenta que le quitamos una
vez 0.1 en el tercer término le quitamos
dos veces 0.1 y en el cuarto término ya
le hemos quitado una dos tres veces 0.1
por lo tanto en fdn debe ser una función
que dependa de n y entonces nos va a
quedar 9.6 menos 0.1 que multiplica a el
número de términos del que estamos
hablando menos 1
es decir le vamos a quitar n 1 veces 0.1
a 9.6 para encontrar el término n y tú
puedes evaluarlo y ver que en verdad
funciona sin nivel de uno bueno pues me
va a quedar uno menos uno lo cual es
cero esto se elimina y solamente me
quedaría 9.6 ahí vamos muy bien si n
vale 2 me quedarían dos menos uno es uno
por lo tanto le quitaríamos solamente
una vez 0.1 a 9.6 y llegaríamos a 9.5 y
así nos podremos mantener evaluando esta
función de hecho podría ser una tabla y
evaluar esta misma función pero aquí la
clave de todo esto de lo que quiero que
te des cuenta es que empiezas en 9.6 y
le vas a quitar 0.1 una vez menos del
número de término que tú estés buscando
esta es la clave por ejemplo si tú
quieres el término 4
bueno pues habrá que restarle tres veces
0.1 a 9.6 entonces cuando en es igual a
4 hemos quitado tres veces 0.1
y date cuenta que va una vez aquí va
otra vez y aquí tenemos la tercera vez
quitamos 0.1 tres veces